if you hit the ball in the proper spot  you almost don't feel it nicely easy so  there's not a lot of movement it's a lot  of shock absorption and just kind of  guiding the ball back but if you get it  just off the mark a little bit farther  back on your head you know you're gonna  feel something like that's going to make  you a little bit that could shake you a  little bit with my young players I'm not  encouraging them to head those balls you  know muscularly they're not strong  enough for the weight of the ball the  speed of the ball open your body as fast  as you can sometimes it is necessary to  head the ball I'm going to teach them  without using the ball itself the timing  of receiving that ball so if faced with  that moment maybe once a game they can  handle it